>> Joe: THAT IS ONE CROSSING N A
SHOT, HE SCORES!
>> Joe: SPACE, TIME, AND THAT
SHOT!
OVER THE RIGHT TRIED TO KEEP IT
.
PLAYERS BACK.
YOU SEE
ISLANDERS COMING AGAIN.
PALMIERI WITH A SHOT.
OFF THE
INJURIES. FERRARO, SECOND
TRI, DOESN'Trendan: PULLS IT
ALL THE WAY TO THE  OTTAWA,
ALL ISSUES, TO TALK TO HIM ABOUT
PLAYERS, HOW BY SOROKIN.
PUCK STILL ALIVE.
DOBSON, ABLE
PELECH, TO THE, PALMIERI DIDN'T
LOT OF IT.
HE IS IN
ATTACKING PLAY
THERE IT, THAT IS RESPONSIBLE.
YOU SEE HIMR THE SHARKS THAT
TOOK THE MOMENTUM AWAY. ON THE .
RIGHT INTENDED FOR  IT
SHARKS, AND BOTHERS HIM
ENOUGH,TO VORK, HE WAS ABLE TO .
CAUSINGAZY BOUNCE, THE FLIP UP.
AND THE BOUNCING PUCK.
THERE IS
THIS COULD HAVE BEEN ICING, THEY
WAVE IT HIP
AND TO GO.
AND A STEPOT WON A GAME
PAST  KARLSSON.